every wild card team will be going on
the road in the opening round uh except
and and well not except uh
notwithstanding the fact that the nfc
east champion will have a worse record
than each of the three wild card teams
barring someone getting hot down the
stretch which is highly unlikely the nfc
east all four teams currently have
three wins
11 weeks they have three wins there will
be multiple teams with better records
than the nfce champion that don't make
the playoffs at all it really is sad
exclamation point but that's the way the
cake has been baked by the nfl ever
since they went to this format back in
2002 with four divisions per conference
and four teams per division guaranteed
home playoff game for the winner of the
division i still don't know who it's
going to be and the eagles even though
they're technically in first place by a
half game they stink
and i know they like to get backed into
a corner and that's when somehow some
way they make magic i don't know that
they're going to do it this year no and
this carson wentz problem isn't going
away no it's not 25 million next year
fully guaranteed they're stuck with
carson wentz for next year now the
organization will say well we're not
stuck with him we want him well maybe
that's why they're saying we want him
because they have no alternative like
the vikings they're not going to say
they don't want kirk cousins they're
stuck with him you sign contracts that
commit you to a guy under the hope that
the guy's going to play great and if he
doesn't you're stuck yeah i they are
they're they're stuck
he's got issues the team's got issues we
know that i mean every week it's just it
seems like they're on a tight rope you
know it's again carson wentz jamming in
there is he going to get strip sacked
fumbled to throw a pick six or whatever
it is
it's all over the place i don't know
maybe this is the year that finally gets
it changed something like that i'm at
the point really
where
first off
i i think after the last few weeks of
football that i've seen i think the
giants are the best team in the nfc's
i'm i'm officially i think willing to
say that we'll see where it goes
but i don't know and the cowboy's
getting a little bit better too they're
gonna make me think here as we go along
too but there's almost a part of me mike
i'm almost rooting for the whole nfc to
lose i want one i really i want i want
three i want three
and 13 in the playoffs i want to see
what it's gonna look like it's like it's
such a bad look a debacle right now i
almost wanted to continue to where it
just looks stupid maybe it does make the
nfl reevaluate but man there's nothing
there of the philadelphia team to look
at them to think oh if they get backed
in the corner what they're going to get
it together they're going to do
something no there's too many issues
there they're they're missing certain
things of their football team this year
and i just don't see that see it coming
together
look at that for carson wentz 14
touchdown passes 14 interceptions a
passer rating of 73.3 that is a career
low and well below
the 2017 numbers that he put together
only two quarterbacks in our database
have a game with two or more
interceptions five or more sacks a
fumble of pick six and a safety jay
fiedler in 2003 versus the patriots and
carson wentz
on sunday against the browns that's
courtesy of pro football reference and
yeah they're just stuck and chris you
know you you're rooting for three and
thirteen three and thirteen is not going
to happen because the eagles worst
possible record is twelve and one and
and
the cowboys in washington get together
on
sunday
and
on thursday excuse me thanksgiving in
the tryptophan game where everyone
should go take a nap but the winner is
going to be
four and seven
and maybe the winner of that game
becomes the the team that acquires the
shine going into december because it is
a big spot because it is a captive
audience because people will be watching
if the cowboys or washington can turn a
one game winning streak into a two-game
winning streak and effectively double
their season victories in a five-day
span that's the team that we're going to
be talking about as the team that can
win the division yeah i mean certainly
could be
you know i mean
washington the defense it is damn good
alex smith he seems to be getting more
and more in a groove here
but man they got they got some tough
games down the stretch that's where it's
just you look at them
dallas i will say i mean it
defense was better yesterday it wasn't
perfect as we know but it was better and
they still
you know have weapons on the offensive
side of the ball where it's hard to
count them out i mean it really is as
dysfunctional as they look there for a
period of time the fact that this
division is so bad and dallas can sit
here and still have a chance
and i don't know still might be able to
say that the best team in the division
here for a few weeks from now is just uh
it's mind-blowing
best team on paper they just haven't
performed yesterday they did in beating
the vikings came from behind back and
forth exciting fourth quarter uh and the
cowboys got it done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports